[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: I'm really
excited to welcome
my dear friend and mentor,
Nely Galan, to Google.
NELY GALAN: So happy to be here.
My god, it's--
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: So
Nely's really, truly
a force to be reckoned with.
She's one of the
first Latina producers
in Hollywood, former president
of entertainment at Telemundo.
She is the Latina Tyler Perry.
[LAUGHTER]
NELY GALAN: She's got it done.
SPEAKER 1: And really excited.
Today, she's a media mogul on
a mission to empower others.
And so I want to take a chance.
If it works, we're going to play
a little sizzle reel that will
tell us more about her journey.
So really important for us to
show that because, again, I
would not be able to do Nely's
journey justice in terms of all
that you've accomplished.
So that collection of your
story is absolutely amazing.
NELY GALAN: Thank you.
SPEAKER 1: And what we're
here to talk about today
is "Self Made."
So it's entrepreneurship
manifesto
that is a "New York
Times" bestseller.
So really applaud you for
that because there are,
how many Latinos
that are bestsellers?
NELY GALAN: Four Latinas in
history, and three of them
are dead celebrities.
And I think that we have to
understand that "The New York
Times" is a big, and having
a "New York Times" bestseller
is very hard to do.
You have to sell x
amount, so many books.
It's a lot of books.
And so we have to be able to
buy things in mass together
to reach those numbers.
For me, it was like
climbing Mount Kilimanjaro
and very important to me
because how thought leaders are
made in America are through
"The New York Times" bestseller.
I have to say that the day
that I met you and Iliana,
who I love from
Google as well, we
had an event together with
women of Silicon Valley,
with Sheryl Sandberg.
And then I had you ladies,
because I was so proud of you,
I said I felt like
a proud mother,
to see you how
beautiful and smart.
And I was just, I mean,
elated to have you.
And that's the day that I
decided to write "Self Made."
SPEAKER 1: Wow.
NELY GALAN: Because
Sheryl Sandberg and I,
she had asked me to do an event.
She knew that I have a
big constituency of Latina
and multicultural women.
She wanted to do an
event for "Lean In."
And I had a very long
talk with her before,
and I said, Cheryl, I'm happy
to do this event with you,
but you have to understand
that the book is not
that relatable to
multicultural women.
So many of us have had
paths that are not linear.
And she was wonderful.
And you were there.
We had a very feisty
conversation about it.
And I'm a big fan of hers.
But that day I thought to
myself, as she was speaking,
I thought, who's going
to tell our stories?
Who's going to tell the
stories of women like us
that are immigrants or
the kids of immigrants
or who have had
detours or women that
are Muslim or
African-American or Asian,
who really come to this
country and reinvent themselves
and are emerging in
countries around the world?
And I heard in my ear,
you do it, you do it.
And then, of course,
sometimes our low self-esteem
shows up and goes,
[SPEAKING SPANISH],,
what do you think you are?
And then I said, if you don't
do it, who is going to do it?
And I did it, and I'm
very proud that I've
spent a year, 140 cities
around the country,
meeting all kinds of
women and really uniting
with not just all multicultural
women but with white women.
And we now know after
the whole election
that this is an incredible
year for all of us
and that we need to
talk about this issue.
SPEAKER 1: We have
power, a lot of power.
NELY GALAN: A lot of power,
power that we don't even
know we have.
SPEAKER 1: Now tell us,
what is "Self Made?"
What does it mean
to be Self Made?
NELY GALAN: So
"Self Made," it so
wonderful to be
in a tech company
and talk about "Self Made"
because it doesn't mean you're
going to leave your job and go
be an entrepreneur tomorrow.
It also doesn't mean, especially
all of you in Silicon Valley,
that one of you is going to go
off and be the next Zuckerberg.
These are one-in-a-million
situations.
But the good news is
Self Made is a mindset.
It begins by thinking like
an owner in what you do now.
You're not going
to leave your job.
You're going to think every day
that you're in business school
working for other people,
using other people's money,
and sitting there
every day and saying,
if this were my company,
what would I do?
Would I spend this money?
And make sure that you let
your bosses know how you feel.
You're practicing being
a founder and an owner.
And if they don't listen
to you, that's fine.
But you have to, every day,
come into work not thinking
victimized, thinking
like an owner.
The future for all of us is to
think and behave like owners.
Then we have to think that
Self Made is a mindset.
And it's a mindset
of understanding
that the United States works
on a premise that most of us
don't know.
The premise is that, to make
it to the end of your life,
you have to make
money while you sleep,
which one of my billionaire
bosses and mentors
told me that, I was like it
sounds like a foreign language.
I didn't even know
what that meant.
That meant that the money
you make at whatever job
you do, whether you work
here, whether you're
a doctor or a lawyer, if
you just count on the money
you make and money
you save, you're
not going to make it to
the end of your life.
So entrepreneurship isn't just
becoming a founder or a maker.
It's also being someone that
makes money, saves money.
Sometimes you have to do it
by starting a side hustle.
And that money you save you
have to invest in, like me,
real estate, which
we'll talk about.
That why I say, don't
buy shoes, buy buildings.
Or invest it in stock.
Or invest it in buying
an existing business
and let other people run
it while you have job.
Or supplier diversity,
where you understand
that there's a lot of
contracts in corporations
and in the government
that are earmarked
for women particularly
and multicultural women
specifically.
And guys, if you
want to make money,
partner with a woman and a
multicultural woman and you'll
do better.
That we understand that, whether
you're an entrepreneur that
leaves your company or not, you
must think entrepreneurially
from this moment on in
your life to make it.
SPEAKER 1: Tell us tell
us about Nely at age 12.
Where did this come from?
When did you become Self Made?
When did you get this
entrepreneurial spirit?
NELY GALAN: I think for me, it
all began in the seventh grade.
I think for so many
of us sometimes
our greatness comes from pain.
I was the kid of immigrants.
We had no money.
My parents came
from communist Cuba.
They lost everything,
including their degrees.
They had to start all over.
I became the hero child.
I had to help them translate
for them, do everything.
And in the seventh grade, we
were having a lot of struggles
financially.
I was in all-girl
Catholic school.
And basically, I would
overhear my parents saying,
what are we going to do?
What are we going to
do, my father would say.
And my mother would
say, [SPEAKING SPANISH]..
And my dad would
say, don't worry.
Jesus will help us.
And I realized that I had
to go help my parents out.
And a lady down the street, an
older Jewish lady, sold Avon.
And she's like,
honey, why don't you
sell Avon and you get
some free lipstick?
I go, I got to
cut a better deal.
And I went and said to her,
I will sell Avon in school,
but I need it to be 50-50.
And I started making money,
$200 a week selling Avon,
paying down my entire
tuition, and then
having the nuns send home
a letter to my parents
so my dad wouldn't be upset that
I was paying down the tuition.
And I brought it home and my
mother goes, what does it say?
And my father goes, your
daughter is a genius
and Jesus helped us after all.
And I think that was the
beginning of the aha.
That, if there is a
problem, we can fix it.
There's no point
in being a victim.
We fix it.
And I think that
life is a series
of those issues that, maybe for
someone else, is a catastrophe.
And for me, it was like the
beginning blocks of my-- you
know when Beyonce talks
about her persona,
Sasha Fierce I am a Latina
immigrant from New Jersey who's
sometimes has self-esteem issues
show up and I don't feel good,
and then I created a persona.
And I got my own version
of Sasha Fierce going on.
I'm a beast.
And it happened
brick by brick, step
by step, learning that no
one else is smarter than us,
that it's a matter of
being louder and braver.
This is not a country
of wimpy people.
of not understanding
the Constitution and
the First Amendment
and not understanding
that you have rights
and that we're all very
much part of this country
and our voice needs to be heard.
I mean, don't you
love seeing a Latina
on mainstream TV defending
women, multicultural women
and Latinas?
Why do we feel like
we can't do that?
Why do we marginalize
ourselves in small situations
when in fact we have all
the power in the world.
Latinas in this country are
the number one emerging market.
That means we are the
number one consumers
in America, together with
African-American women,
Asian women, Middle
Eastern women.
If we unite together,
there is no company
that can survive without us.
So how do we not put that
information inside our bodies
and become empowered
and know that we have
all the power in the world.
SPEAKER 1: We take ownership.
We are Self Made.
It's a mentality,
changing the mindset.
NELY GALAN: That's right.
It's a mindset shift.
SPEAKER 1: Now, there is
a moment in your journey
when you were working
for a corporation.
NELY GALAN: Yes.
SPEAKER 1: And you
realized at that moment
that you were
acting like an owner
but you really weren't an owner.
Can you tell us a little bit?
NELY GALAN: So I got into
television very early on.
I was lucky because I wrote an
article to "Seventeen" magazine
about why you should
never send your kid
to all-girl Catholic school,
and they published it.
And it was a big
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
in my family.
And as a result,
"Seventeen" magazine
offered me the youngest guest
editorship in their history.
So again, that's when I learned
it doesn't pay to be wimpy.
Speak up.
And I got into
"Seventeen" magazine,
which led me to television,
which in my wildest
dreams I would never have done.
And very early on,
in television I
was interviewing
a lot of people,
and I met a gentleman who was a
very big producer in Hollywood.
And he's like, are you Latina?
What are you?
And I said, yeah, I am.
And he said, I just bought
the first Spanish TV station
in America.
And he's like, why don't
you come and work for me?
And I go, excuse me.
I work for CBS.
Why do I want to work for some
rinky-dinky Spanish TV station?
And he's like, I'm rich.
Are you rich?
He goes, young
lady, what would it
mean to be employee one of a
business that's going to be
a multibillion dollar business?
And I was like, oh
my god, he sounds
a little smarter than me.
And I think that was my first
attempt at not really thinking
any more about what
is my career path,
but who are the people
that I'm going to follow
that are smarter than me?
I went and at 22
years of age ran,
I was the general manager--
the youngest general
manager in the country--
of the first Latino
TV station, which
is now Telemundo but back then
it was an independent station.
I killed myself.
I thought like an owner.
I worked 24 hours a day.
I had no personal life.
And three years later,
I walk into work
and they had sold the company.
And I went to see
my boss, and I said,
how could you do this to me?
This is my baby.
And I'm crying and
bawling, everything
they tell you not to do.
And he's like, stop, young lady.
Those are my chips.
If you want to play,
go get your own chips.
And that is the
moment I had to mourn
that I was losing
my baby, and then I
said I have to start
my own business.
And so I started a business
at 25 making TV shows,
or that's what I thought
I was going to do.
And for four years, I
did not make a penny.
I would tell you the opposite.
Do not leave your job.
Don't just go bootstrapping
without knowing
what you're going to do.
I have a whole formula
for you, but I did that.
And can you imagine
the Latino parents?
Por favor, find the husband.
You're losing your looks.
And four years later, I
was like praying to God.
Dear God, por favor,
throw me a bone.
Everybody thinks I'm a loser.
It was not cool to be
an entrepreneur then.
All my friends were like,
dude, can you get a job?
What's your problem?
And in the fourth
year, I got invited
to a Chamber of Commerce event.
And I went.
And I always say, in
life, if you show up,
maybe something happens,
maybe nothing happens.
But if you don't show up,
nothing happens-- guaranteed.
I went, and I started
asking people,
what's wrong with
my business plan?
And they said immediately,
they were like, your business
plan is wrong.
There is no pipeline
for your content.
There's only one station.
You need to go build the
pipeline and the distribution.
So I switched my business
plan to launching TV channels
around the world
for big companies.
So it was supplier
diversity in a way.
So I basically went to work
with Fox, HBO, ESPN, Sony,
and I would take their brand
and launch it in Latin America.
SPEAKER 1: And they would fund?
NELY GALAN: They would fund it.
It was my business.
So if it screwed up, they
could get rid of me easily.
It was my own business.
And then I launched
it separately,
and I launched 10
channels that way.
And then the original
TV station that I ran
was bought by an American
insurance company,
and they had bought
a bunch of stations.
And they didn't know how
to run a Latino network.
So it went into bankruptcy.
Sony bought it.
Sony was my client.
I had launched their
channels abroad.
And I was the only
Latina that they
knew that had fiscal
responsibility
for large entities
of theirs abroad.
And so they basically
offered to buy my business
and offered me the
presidency of entertainment,
which is running the network.
That's the creative
job in a network.
And so I ran Telemundo
for four years,
and I went back
into corporate life.
So I understand
very much becoming
Self Made as an
intraentrepreneur
and as an entrepreneur
outside of a corporation.
And both ways is very important
because only in a corporation
do you learn how
to scale something.
SPEAKER 1: Yes.
I think we are
all learning that.
I think even myself.
Myself and Iliana who's
here have coined ourselves
as the intrapreneurs, creating
and seeing opportunities
where they don't exist.
Now, tell me, so you mentioned
your mom at one point
and your parents were
saying, andale, you
need to get a husband.
And you mentioned in
your book that there's
no such thing as Prince
Charming or Princess Charming.
NELY GALAN: Well, I
think it is a bigger
idea than even how I say it.
I say there is no
Prince Charming,
and I don't mean that
against guys or anything.
I think there's no Prince
Charming for any of us.
I think the idea that a mate
or a boss or a corporation
or a government or a president
is here to save us is false.
I think that, when you work for
other people, you often think,
whether you're a man
or woman, my boss
is going to see how great I am
and give me the big promotion.
And your boss has their own
problems in their personal life
and in their business life.
And sometimes the
company you work for--
I mean, you guys
are lucky like I
was-- in an emerging
field at the time,
and you're all in
an emerging field.
But companies go
through ups and Downs,
and they really are
not worried about you.
And so it's really about
changing your mindset
from a victim and thinking that
any job is good or bad to I
have to make whatever
job I have under whatever
circumstances a lesson,
a learning lesson
to this puzzle that is my life.
That little by little,
all the puzzle pieces
are going to make sense because
you are on a journey that's
going to take you somewhere
where all the puzzle pieces are
going to come in handy.
SPEAKER 1: Now, speaking
of changing mindset,
so one thing that I really
related to in your book
was the notion of our
relationship with fear
and failure.
Especially as the
Latino community,
I think we oftentimes
are more risk averse.
So what can you say
in terms of kind
of what you've written
in your book, advice
to us to change that mindset?
NELY GALAN: So I think
my book, I really
wanted Latinos to see a Latina--
and not just
Latinos, everybody--
to see that a woman of color was
speaking about money and power.
Very important.
And that a Latina woman
would say in a book,
I always wanted to
be a millionaire.
And not from a place of greed
because, in our culture,
it's being rich in
every way that matters--
but from a place
of knowing my power
and knowing that it's
possible and knowing
that that's why we came here.
But what gets in the way of that
for all of us, at least for me,
fear and fear of failure.
It happens every day of my life
still, every day of my life.
So what I say in the
book is that to make it
to the end of your life you
have to change your relationship
to fear and failure.
And for me, I've had to turn
fear and failure into my best
friends.
Fear shows up every day,
and it's not a real thing.
It's a feeling.
And what comes up for all of
us, which is human, is run away,
run away.
Go away.
Don't do it.
And for me-- and all of
you in the tech world--
know that a brain, just like
a computer, can be rewired.
You have to rewire your brain.
You have to tell yourself, like
I tell myself every day, OK,
fear shows up--
I call her a she.
And I go, OK, you're
telling me I have to do it.
Do it, do it, do it anyway.
When my book was
coming out, my dream
was to have Suzy Orman write
the foreword to my book.
As a woman of color,
the only person
I'd ever hear as a woman talk
about money was Suzy Orman.
I was obsessed with her.
And I wrote her
this magical email.
I barely knew her.
I met her three times, but she
wasn't my friend or anything.
I wrote her a magical email.
And I was ready to send it, and
my low self-esteem showed up.
[SPEAKING SPANISH] Who
do you think you are?
Like, la Suzy doesn't
have time for you.
And I was like, do it anyway
because I've wired my brain.
I say it to myself every day, do
it anyway, do it anyway, do it
anyway.
And I went click, send.
And five minutes later,
Suzy said yes, I'll do it.
Now, that doesn't always happen.
But if you don't do it anyway,
maybe 50% chance it'll happen,
50% it won't.
But you've got to
keep doing it anyway.
And then my other thing
was, in our culture,
failing is like the worst, which
we know in Silicon Valley it's
like high five.
Fail!
High five, next.
You're around the
corner from the answer.
But we're not raised like that.
So my other biggest fear
was fear of failure.
And I have failed.
If I showed you my failure tape,
we'd all be crying right now.
I have failed thousands
and thousands of times.
To win three times in
your life, you better
be failing thousands
of times or you're not
going to win three times.
And that's all
anybody remembers.
So how did I rewire my
brain around failure
when I failed so many
times in my personal life,
in my business life,
in my financial-- fail?
I've had to say to
myself, OK, cry it out.
Cry it out.
Go mourn.
And then get back on the horse.
Get back on the horse.
Because if I don't
pull myself out of it,
around the corner from
my greatest failures
have been my greatest successes.
And if I didn't wait, it
wouldn't have happened.
So that's very important.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
I think oftentimes
I've even faced that.
I call it the imposter
syndrome that we
bring with us like in
our everyday lives,
us questioning if
we should be here.
Especially in the
tech industry, there
is this large
conversation that we all
hear every day around diversity
and the lack of diversity.
And so us killing the
imposter syndrome,
and I've also said I leave
that girl out the door.
NELY GALAN: Well, let's talk
about that, that diversity
and imposter syndrome because
I feel like the diversity
is such a hot potato, and I
think we need to blow it up.
Because diversity,
to me, the way--
and especially,
I'm older than you,
so I grew up in a whole
other world of diversity--
I think diversity means
somebody is doing us a favor.
And I think we need to
like blow that thing up
because the truth of the matter
is, multicultural people are
about to become the majority in
this country by the year 2022.
Number two, when multicultural
women are the number one
consumer in America,
the answer is
we're doing everybody
else a favor.
And if the company doesn't
look like all of us,
it will sooner or
later fail because that
means you have no relationship
to your customer, the number
one customer in the world.
Period.
So you really have
to take that in.
So somehow, we've told ourselves
a story about diversity.
Blow that word up
because they are
lucky to have us because we
represent their number one
customer.
So let's not ever
think that again.
SPEAKER 1: I love it.
Now, how is it that
you-- in your book,
you talk about in order
for you to be chosen you
have to choose yourself first.
NELY GALAN: That's right.
SPEAKER 1: How do
you go about that?
Tell us a few.
NELY GALAN: Well,
if I ask a man--
as someone who
worked in television,
has worked in television
for many years,
I cast a lot of people.
And let's say I'm
casting a cooking show.
And I go up to a man and I
say, well, what do you do?
Oh, I'm a chef.
I've been a chef.
I'm an award-winning chef.
And maybe they just
started six months ago.
If I say that to a
woman, you guys go,
oh, I kind of can
cook really well.
I go, well, are you
a chef or not a chef?
If you don't declare
yourself, how
am I supposed to give
you an opportunity.
I think that we have to forget
humility is a beautiful thing
except at work.
You really have to
declare yourself.
You have to know who you are
and know what you're good at
and say it and call it
out and raise your hand
and show up at
events and speak up.
That's where Cheryl is right.
You have to lean in.
Right?
And I think to not
understand that we live
in a world of loud people--
this is a loud country.
It does not pay
[SPEAKING SPANISH]..
And that's what
I tell everybody.
I'm going to just
tell you right now,
I could never as a Latina
from New Jersey, immigrant
with my humble parents,
have raised millions
of dollars for my businesses
if I didn't go and take
acting lessons.
I recommend everybody
take acting lessons.
It's super fun.
It's a great way to meet
people that you want to date.
And it's going to serve
you very well in life.
Because, I'm super
introverted-- you
would never know that, right?
Super, super introverted.
But I've had to cultivate
my Sasha Fierce side.
And I think that you do
it by pretending you're
someone else in a character.
Every time I've
raised money, I made
believe I was my old Jewish
bosses that were like,
if you don't give
me the money, you're
going to miss the opportunity.
I can even get into their voice.
And when I spoke inside their
body, I would get money.
I go, man, this stuff works.
So I want you all to
think that we can't all
be good at everything.
Cultivate these sides of us.
In order for me
to sell TV shows,
even though I was an introvert,
I had to go and pitch the show
and make people
excited about it.
I had to cultivate
a sales persona.
SPEAKER 1: Now, so it's noisy--
you mentioned noisy earlier--
which brings me to
another point is
to make an immigrant
your role model, which
I think is a really interesting
point because, in today's
political world, to say that
I think is a strong statement.
It's a statement that
I think is beautiful,
but maybe some other people may
have a different point of view.
NELY GALAN: I think
everything that I am
is because I'm an immigrant.
I think it's my superpower.
It is my secret sauce
because immigrants--
80% of CEOs in America
are immigrants by the way,
so that should
tell us something--
I think that immigrants
come to this country
and are super patriotic.
We've come from a place where
something bad has happened,
and we are grateful to be here.
And we are hard working.
We're willing to do
whatever it takes.
We're willing to still bootstrap
and do whatever it takes.
And on top of that, we have
an incredible value system
that I don't think
people realize.
The other day, I
spoke at the FBI.
I've spoken at the military.
You wouldn't think that
a Latina immigrant,
I cry at the American flag.
I cry when I'm
around the military.
I loved being at the
FBI the other day.
I am proud to be an
American in this country.
My mother always said to me, you
have the best of both worlds.
You get to be Latina and
passionate and colorful
and eat Latin food, and you
get to be fully American.
And I think that says it all.
So in my book, I wrote
an entire chapter.
Think like an immigrant.
Make an immigrant
your role model.
You will not go wrong
because immigrants
are leading the life, and
they are holding the values
that we've lost in this country.
SPEAKER 1: And
talk to us about--
so I majored in finance
as an undergrad,
so I've always been
really intrigued
because I felt like
growing up coming
from an impoverished
background I
wanted to make sure that I
understood how to manage money.
That was my important thing.
We don't have a lot of it.
Let me ensure that
I manage it well.
And in your book, you talk about
the hidden money in America
and in your home.
That was eye opening to me.
NELY GALAN: Yeah.
Thank you.
I think that's the big
secret in the book.
First of all, I always
say math doesn't lie.
I am very blessed
because I've always
been pretty good at math,
but I didn't really like it.
And when I went to
work at Channel 47,
I realized I couldn't
read financial statements.
And I hired a math
tutor, and I realized
I was very good
at math but I had
been taught math incorrectly.
And so I say that because so
many of us are afraid of math,
and yet math is super
creative and fun.
And I believe that why I've
been successful in my TV life
is because I've had a real
math head, because math
is very important.
In the book, I talk about
the hidden money in America
because this is one of
those things in this country
that we don't know.
There are so many opportunities
that your taxpayer dollars
offer you, and yet it
doesn't get marketed to us.
So we don't know that
there is billions
of dollars in the
federal government,
in the Small Business
Administration
and the Department of Commerce.
There's IT in the
Department of Commerce
that we could apply for and
then start a business tomorrow
with their IT that they funded.
There is money for not
just to fund your business,
but also to buy a building,
to buy a building.
Every entrepreneur
should, at some point,
try to buy the building
their business is in.
The building will be worth more
than your business eventually.
This real estate that
Google is in eventually
will be worth more than
Google, I promise you.
So there's so much money there.
There's so much money
in supplier diversity
in every corporation in America.
And that means
contracts that are
designated for women- and
minority-owned businesses
first.
Now, if we don't apply,
other people can apply.
But why are we not
applying when there's
a million nonprofits
in America that
help you fill out the paperwork
and teach you how to do it.
There are grants.
People talk about how there's
no money to start a business.
There is so much money in grants
at every nonprofit in America
for starting up businesses
that we don't even know about.
And so there is all this
money that everybody
says there's no money
out there, but it's
just that the information
hasn't gotten to you.
So what happens?
A lot of white guys
in corporations
find out about this
money because they
have consultants in Washington.
And they go find a woman or a
minority to front a company,
and they go get the money.
Why are the rest of
us not doing that?
Again, lack of knowledge,
lack of understanding
the system of this
country where we have
to make money while we sleep.
SPEAKER 1: I'm
still working on it.
NELY GALAN: And becoming
Self Made and even being
millionaires is not some elite
thing that is only the lady
that started Spanx or Zuckerberg
or these one-of-a-kind unicorn
people.
No.
If I that started as an
intern, went to an assistant,
worked my way up, made
no money for a long time,
started really making money
at 32, lived beneath my means.
Even at 32 when I
started making money,
I didn't go buy a
lavish car or a house.
I started buying
commercial real estate,
using the tax laws
of this country.
$5,000, flip the buildings.
Kept flipping the buildings.
1031 exchange, which is a
thing in this country that
allows you not to pay
tax on your earnings
if you keep flipping the
money forward and buying
more real estate.
And by 45, I work because I
want to and not because I have
to, which means I could retire.
Now, retiring is
very different if you
live in Bentonville,
Arkansas, than if you
live in San Francisco.
But all of us can do it not
from a place of grandiosity,
not from a place
of being a founder,
not from a place of
being an inventor,
but like a turtle like me--
one step at a time,
deciding you're
going to do three things
a year, every Sunday three
things every week to get
to the three things a year,
every day three things to get
to the three things of the week.
Like a turtle, slowly
you win the race.
SPEAKER 1: So don't buy
shoes, buy buildings.
NELY GALAN: Absolutely.
Do not go for
instant gratification
because you're sad or
you feel bad or whatever.
No, because you're going to get
over that purchase in a week.
Have a big dream.
I wrote down when I was
20, I want to own a house--
not own a mortgage,
own a house--
own a building, own
a business, have
a house in my country
of origin, which
it's not going to be Cuba,
so it's going to be Miami.
And I have it.
I want to retire by 65.
I got to my number at 45
without being J-Lo, Beyonce,
an athlete, or Mark
Zuckerberg-- none of the above.
And I still made it.
So what is everybody
else's problem?
If I can do it, all of you
can, should, and will do it.
SPEAKER 1: It's only
a matter of time.
NELY GALAN: That's right.
SPEAKER 1: So tell me,
did you have a mentor
in terms of real estate?
NELY GALAN: Great question.
Well, I'll tell you this.
This is in my book, too.
A lot of people come
up to me and they say,
can you be my mentor?
I go, mi amor, I don't have
enough hours in the day
to be everybody's mentor.
I'll tell you this.
I have had a lot of mentors,
but not one of my mentors
knows they were my mentor.
So when I found people that
I thought were super smart,
I would stay late and
hang out with them.
I'd volunteer.
I'd read everything about them.
Everything.
I would go to every
event they spoke at.
I would write down
everything they said.
And what I do--
and I really think this works--
for those of you that
are very young listening
that are in your 20s, go to 50
because to you that's old age.
To those of us that are
older, go to 80, 85.
Start looking at people that
are the oldest you think
they can be and start making a
composite person of everything
you love about somebody.
We're all human.
We have good sides
and bad sides.
You can't find one
perfect person.
And that's why people
get disappointed
because they think they're
going to find everything
in one person.
Forget about it.
You see this person
over here, and you
go, I like the way
they've dealt with money.
I like how they live in old age.
I like this person, how
they deal with family.
I like this person's
spirituality.
And make a composite and
make a picture of it.
And write down
everything you want.
And go to 85, or to 50
if you're in your 20s,
and work your way backwards.
I did it to 50, and I
saw all these people
that I wanted to be.
And I got to 50.
And now, I'm thinking
about 85 or 90 or even 100
because I plan to
live a very long time.
SPEAKER 1: All right.
So three pieces
of advice in terms
of making money in our sleep.
NELY GALAN: Oh, easy.
Number one, do not
leave your job.
Number two, lower your overhead.
I have to give you
more than three.
Number three, start a side
hustle one hour a week.
And you're not cheating
on your company
because if you're not doing this
you're not bringing anything
back to your company.
You need to be out there
doing the shared economy.
So ladies, clean out your
closets, the quinceanera dress,
whatever you want.
One hour a week sell
something in your house.
Start there, and
put that money away.
Everyone should have a compound
interest account in the bank.
I always tell, if
you're 20-something
and you put $5 a day away
in a compound interest,
you will be a millionaire by 50.
So let's just start there.
One hour a week side
hustle, put the money away,
lower your overhead.
It's really fun to
watch money grow.
When you have two
years of money saved,
two years of salary, one of
those years is for a rainy day.
The other one is
your investment fund.
I want you to think--
you don't all have
to be entrepreneurs
that create businesses-- what
are you going to invest in?
Real estate?
How much has real
estate gone up here?
Crazy.
SPEAKER 1: It's insane, yeah.
NELY GALAN: If not, look
at a little business
down your street, some old
person that's going to retire
and their kids don't
want the business.
Pick something that
already exists.
Don't invent something.
That is for the
0.111 percentile.
Franchises.
You know what the number
one franchise in America
is right now?
Tutoring.
If I had to do my life over
again, I'd buy 20 franchises--
I'm going to make my kid buy
them-- of different sorts,
food, yoga, tutoring, whatever.
I mean, they give you the
color-by-number how to do it.
Why does everything
have to be so hard?
You save some money,
put it in, and the thing
makes money while you sleep.
So there are many, many,
many ways to become Self
made, and we all
must do it, even
if you work in a corporation.
You have to be an
intrapreneur and you
have to be cultivating your
entrepreneurial Self-Made life.
SPEAKER 1: Looking
back, and I think
I know the answer
to this, but what
is your most proudest
moment looking back?
NELY GALAN: Well, two things.
Obviously, my son that I gave
birth to, which I don't even
know how I did that because I
didn't know what I was doing.
But my parents are
very happy about that.
And I have four stepkids.
If I had to do my
life over again,
I think I'd have more
kids because I think
that's a great part of life.
SPEAKER 1: When did
you realize that?
NELY GALAN: When my time clock
was ticking so hard that--
no, but I realized it now.
I've realized it in
the last few weeks
because my son is leaving.
This is his senior
year in high school.
And I'm like, why didn't I
have a few more waiting behind?
This is too much.
I left home and left
my mother there crying.
Por favor, don't leave.
And I left.
And now, I feel like,
man, karma's a bitch.
But my other part is the moment
is that I started in television
and I started college,
and I dropped out
because I got so many
jobs in television.
And really, at that
time an emerging field,
my life experience
was really valuable.
But I always wanted
to go back to school,
and I really felt as I got
older like there was real gaps--
not just in my education
because my business education
I had gotten it in other ways--
but my emotional
intelligence and my ability
to read people and my
ability to do other things.
And so my second
proudest moment is
that I took a four-year
sabbatical, which
for a type-A workaholic
is very hard to do.
So I only did it when I
felt like I had enough money
to do it.
And I went back to
school and I got
a master's and doctorate in
clinical psychology, which
I'm very proud of.
So I can be all your shrinks.
[APPLAUSE]
And I don't think I
would have written
this book had I not
done that because I
had to go back to school.
My first professor said,
you write like a rapper.
Because, you know,
I was in TV where
there were pithy little
marketing things that I wrote.
And he's like, here's
Strunk and White.
Learn to write all over again.
And I go, I love this.
And I ended up writing
97 papers and a thesis
and a dissertation.
And I don't think I would
have had the discipline
to go back and write
this book, which I
had done after going to school.
SPEAKER 1: And tell us
what's on the horizon.
What's next?
NELY GALAN: Well, I
have been on, as I said,
a 130-city book tour.
I first need a rest.
And I think my priority
for the rest of the year
and into next year
early next year
is, first of all, to analyze
what I've learned on the road.
I've met so many men and women.
I feel like I've
been Hillary Clinton
for a year, city by city by city
meeting all kinds of people.
And I really want to
analyze that and figure out
what to do with
that information,
like a good entrepreneur.
But also, I want
to focus on my son.
It's his last year
of high school,
and I really want
to be there for him
and really help him out.
And then, I'm very
open to all new things
because I think the number
one thing that I would say
is important for all of us is
to evolve and grow everyday.
There's so much that I know now
and so much that I've mastered
and yet so much
that I don't know.
And I think that we all have to
wake up every day understanding
that we know nothing at all.
And I think when
you think like that,
magical things happen
to you, and you're
open to new ideas,
new possibilities.
And I'm right now
sitting on two years--
and a book, where I did so
much research-- of knowledge
that I have to
now spend the time
to take all that research
and development that I've
done and figure out
what do I do with that.
SPEAKER 1: And any
advice for the Latinos
here at Google and just
in the tech industry?
I know you're going to be
meeting hundreds of more
Latinos.
What do you think that
we should be thinking of,
and what can we
be doing more of?
NELY GALAN: Well, I think--
I mean, I've said this before--
but you all have to
be louder and braver.
It kills me to have everything
that's happened this year
and to have my
African-American friends say,
why are you Latinos so quiet?
Why do you take it?
And I understand why we
take it because that's
how we were raised and
it's our parents baggage.
They're afraid.
But it's all of your jobs to
not carry that baggage with you.
You have to know there's
nothing to be afraid of.
No one is going to
do anything to you.
It's all BS.
Nothing is going to happen.
On the contrary.
And I think that the best advice
I can give you is sometimes I
understand that,
although I believe
the answer for all of
us is uniting with all
the other multiculturals
and learning from each other
because we all have different
traits and different skills,
I understand that
sometimes let's
say our voice can't be the voice
of an African-American sister
who is very empowered
and very strong.
Maybe that's not us.
But one of our
super super powers
is we're very vulnerable people.
And so sometimes, when someone
says something in front of you
and it's really like not cool--
sometimes they don't
even mean, it's
just that it's their learned
wiring and behavior--
you have to say something
like, excuse me,
what did you just say?
You just stabbed
me in the heart.
That was so painful to hear.
That is so hurtful.
And that's just as strong
as saying, excuse me.
There is many ways to
skin the cat and be loud.
Maybe it's not
always being loud.
Maybe it's being
honest and vulnerable.
But we have to speak up.
I don't allow people to say
things about my culture--
not in public.
And by the way,
you don't think I
was afraid to go on Fox
News knowing that they
were going to ream me?
I broke out in hives,
but I did it anyway.
And I didn't die.
I said a few things about
immigrants, and on social media
people were trolling
me like crazy.
So what?
The next day it's over.
You're not going to die.
Nothing's going to happen.
But you're going
to gain character.
And there's
something that no one
can take away from you when you
speak on behalf of your family.
SPEAKER 1: That's beautiful.
I want to make sure that
you get any last remarks,
but I also want to see if
anyone here in the audience
has questions for Nely.
This has been my magic moment
at Google, having you here.
It's been a while we've
been planning this,
but I'm really excited.
NELY GALAN: I'm so
proud of all of you.
And Iliana, I'm so
proud of you, too.
Love you guys.
Yeah.
So I want to hear questions.
Don't you guys want to
know about Donald Trump?
OK.
So I'll just tell you a quick
"Celebrity Apprentice" story
because I think you'll enjoy it.
So when I ran
Telemundo, we sold it
and NBC gave me a very
big deal to produce shows.
So I produced about 700
shows in English and Spanish.
That's why I say I'm
Tyler Perry Latina.
And I get a call
one day from NBC,
and they said, we want you to
be on "Celebrity Apprentice."
and I was like, well, I
produce reality shows.
I'm not in them.
And they said, no.
The president of
NBC said, I really
think you would be great
because Donald Trump is tough.
And we think if we put a
Latina actress or something,
he might really insult them.
You've worked for
six billionaires,
and you've had them as clients.
And they're a lot worse
than Donald Trump.
SPEAKER 1: You can take it.
NELY GALAN: You can take it.
And the truth is, I've
had to take it, you guys.
I've worked in Hollywood.
I have been yelled
at, screamed at.
I've had people be
very disrespectful,
and I had to not take it
personally and put people
in their place.
I had to go into
my other persona.
So I said, all right.
And they go, we're not asking
you, we're kind of telling you.
And I was like, but
I'm not a celebrity.
And they're like,
why don't you just
say thank you for millions
of dollars of publicity
for your personal brand?
And I was like, OK, thank you.
And I went on
"Celebrity Apprentice."
And in the first episode,
Donald Trump yelled at me.
I did what I would
have done with any of them.
You saw me on the show.
I would very
respectfully-- because I
didn't do it, as I say in
Spanish, [SPEAKING SPANISH]..
I would do it very
like, I'm sorry
but no, I don't agree with you.
No, we're not.
And we got into these
very feisty conversations.
And after the first episode
when we were off camera,
he said to me, oh, it's so great
that you yelled back at me.
How great.
Keep doing it.
We're going to get
a lot of ratings.
Latinos will love you
because they don't like me,
and it will be great that
you're yelling at me.
And that tells you
a lot about him.
He loves to argue for sport.
And he was very into the
ratings and very much
the value of his property.
But I actually had a great
time on "Celebrity Apprentice"
because I was partnered up
with Gene Simmons from KISS.
And when he's not being
the guy from KISS,
he's like a Jewish dad.
He was very lovely.
And one day, he
says to me, Galan,
you're such a smart
girl, but I feel
like you're always climbing
a mountain the hardest
possible way.
You're struggling like an
immigrant that just arrived.
And I thought it was like he
was stabbing me in the heart
because I thought that's true.
Sometimes as Latinos
we don't even
know how to enjoy the
journey if it's not hard,
if we're not struggling, if
it's not climbing a mountain
the hardest possible way.
And so I've given a
lot of thought to that,
and I think what I need to
work on the rest of my life--
because God knows I'm
not a baked cake--
is achieving things with
ease versus struggling
so much, having to suffer so
much to make things happen.
AUDIENCE: Nely, quick question
on the commercial real estate
front.
What's the biggest lesson
learned or the hardest thing
that you had to figure out
in commercial real estate?
NELY GALAN: Well, I think I
did find mentors in real estate
as well.
I have a mentor in real estate.
Her name is Elaine,
and she's 75 years old.
And one of those people that
I met that I just thought she
was brilliant.
She was developing real estate.
And I started taking
her to dinner.
And to this day,
she is my mentor.
I don't buy a
building without her.
I mean, at all.
If she doesn't OK
the building, it
doesn't happen because, as
she has taught me very well,
in real estate it's all math.
And I have to tell
you something.
In my TV life, I've made five
times the money in real estate
than in my TV life.
And I think it's because my TV
life is creative and emotional.
Sometimes I've made
bad judgment calls
because I fall in
love with a show.
I don't fall in
love with buildings.
If the math doesn't work,
you don't buy the building.
Period.
So there's something
about mission and money,
having something in your life
that you love, and there's
nothing wrong with that.
But until you're rich,
as my boss told me,
the money part has
to take precedence
because you have so many years
of life force, of energy,
where if you're doing
five things at once
I don't feel sorry
for you because you
have a lot of energy.
Later in your life, you're
not going to want to do that.
So to me, yes, you
have to find mentors.
You have to go to
events like this
because if that's something
that interests you that is
a path that works--
linearly, slowly.
All the tax incentives and all
the tax laws are in your favor.
Hence, Donald Trump.
When he says, I don't pay very
many taxes, he's not lying.
That part is true.
All of us can pay lesser taxes
if we follow the tax laws
and invest in things that
give us all kinds of benefits.
AUDIENCE: Who are
your new role models,
someone in the last five years?
NELY GALAN: Well, I'll tell you.
My role model that I
think about most often.
I have a few, but I
love Gloria Steinem
because I love
Gloria Steinem at 85.
She is beautiful.
She is really deep and
profound and peaceful.
And yet, she's still
doing her work.
She still shows up and
speaks and all that.
I also had a professor in school
who was 80-- at the time, 82,
she's now 85--
who had gone back to school
at 50 after raising five kids,
had become the world's foremost
expert on Sigmund Freud,
has written six books
on Sigmund Freud.
And now, she travels all
over the world lecturing
in her expertise,
which is Sigmund Freud.
And at 82, she looked
like she was 50.
And she really
inspired me in school
to find, what is my true path?
There's a lot of TV
producers, but what
I thought that I offer
the world uniquely
is from a multicultural voice.
I really walk the walk of
an entrepreneurial person,
of a Self-Made woman.
I've sacrificed what you need
to sacrifice to get to my age
and be Self Made and be set.
And I felt like it is my duty.
And when I saw Sheryl, it
concretely was clear to me.
It's my duty to pass that on--
obviously, first to my
Latinas because I love you
guys and I want you
all to succeed--
then to other multicultural
women and men,
and then to all young people
because I don't want everyone
to think that you have
to be that one-of-a-kind,
unicorn person that makes it
big when all of us can do it,
as I said, like a turtle.
SPEAKER 1: I know we're
going to be doing a book
signing after this, but I
want to thank you again,
Nely Galan, for being here,
joining us for Talks at Google
in collaboration with Hola,
Google's Hispanic Googler
network, and talking about
"Self Made," "New York Times"
bestselling book, "Becoming
Empowered, Self-Reliant,
and Rich in Every Single Way."
NELY GALAN: Rich in every way.
That's the key.
And why are we doing this?
To pass the torch to the next
generation of a mindset that
is self-reliant, that
thinks like owners,
that multicultural
people particularly
think like owners
in everything we do.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you.
NELY GALAN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]